hello everyone and thank you for joining
our webinar today i am carmen leon i
lead the hybrid data management business
at ibm
and with me today albeit six feet apart
i have vikramarali who is our vice
president of
development for hybrid data management
we also have microneed joining us
virtually mike leads the north america
business for
data warehousing and i would like to
call mike actually one of the netezza
originals because he's been
with netiza i believe since 2004 or 2005
is that right mike that's right but yeah
by the teaser originals carmen is going
to call me old there
[Laughter]
so we just celebrated our one year
anniversary of launching the teaser
performance server
and i figured now is a good time for us
to kind of do a little get together
share with our audience some of the
updates that we've made to the solution
and for those who are just learning
about neteaser performance server
kind of do a little refresh for them as
well does it sound good to you all
really good i know netezza has been a
very popular enterprise data warehouse
for almost two decades now
and thousands and thousands of our
customers have been using this
as their data warehouse for two decades
so the new neteza netiza performance
server
now actually sits on a containerized
platform running on red hat openshift
can you talk a little bit about
how our customers are specifically
benefiting from running on this
containerized platform
absolutely so one of the things we first
did when we introduced neteza
performance server last year
was we took the code which was 32-bit we
made it a 64-bit code we had to upgrade
that and we containerized
it is a microservice based architecture
so we containerized the entire engine
the advantage to our customers the
benefit to our customer is the low
administration cost the high
availability that they get from
containerization
and running on openshift but more than
that since we have now standardized on
openshift
netezza can technically run anywhere
openshift is running
so right now we have it available on
our on-prem product which is the cloud
pack for data system but we also
have it available on the cloud and the
reason we are able to do that
is because we standardized on openshift
and it is a completely containerized
platform
that sounds great so before we dive into
the
speeds and feeds of the product for our
audience who is learning about native
performance server for the very first
time
mike i think we need to address kind of
the elephant in the room the number one
thing that our customers really really
care about
which is code based interoperability so
mike can you talk a little bit about the
teaser performance server and whether
it has the exact same netiza code base
or not
yeah absolutely right so it probably is
the number one thing
top of mind as we go out to the you know
to the customer base et cetera they want
to know how you brought these modernized
features but at the same time have
maintained
the dna of native is it really the
teaser right
is it green does it bleed the green etc
um
and it does right so you know we are you
know i'm personally 15
16 years into this brand at this point
um so it's the evolution of a code base
that has continued over the years
and this is the native code base now
later on we're
likely to talk about some of the new
features and what we've done to enable
you know cloud deployments et cetera uh
but it is netezza
so picking up all your work with bi
etl etc is all in scope with that code
base
fantastic so since it's the same natiza
code
same nps engine it sounds like if our
customer wants to migrate from their old
netizea over to the new native it's not
really
a migration anymore it's more of an
upgrade is that right vikram
that is correct so as mike mentioned the
migration we call it an upgrade
it's using one command it's called nz
migrate
that is one way of doing it there's
another way customers could actually
move to our new netizea performance
server
the compatibility is so high that they
can just back up
their older system and restore it into
the newer system
so when we say we are 100 compatible we
are truly compatible
imagine backing up an older system and
just restoring it so that's
another way for customers to just move
from their older to newer systems
i think i've heard customers moving from
old to new and over a weekend is that
right
that is true that is true so we we've
had customers
from when we installed the product to
when they go to production it can happen
in a matter of weeks the fastest the
customer has gone is about four to five
weeks i would say
but that's because they include testing
and so on but once the system is up and
running we've installed it it's up and
running
they can actually it's just the time
that it takes for them to either run an
ng migrate
or just do a backup and restore it's
it's that simple
that's fantastic so very simple very
easy for our customers to upgrade from
old to new
now going along the same theme around
simplicity
i know one of the things that our native
customers have also really loved
is just how simple it is for them to use
netezza
so vikram is a new natisa just as simple
in terms of you know development
deployment
ongoing administration and maintenance
absolutely so
one of the things when we were uh
working on releasing the neonatisa one
of the things we wanted to always keep
in mind
is the simplicity of neteza customers
like nadisa because you don't have
to monitor it you don't have to
administer it you just install it
you throw queries at it applications can
connect to it
and and you're on your way so i would
say there is zero administration
and that is something that we have
carried on with netiza performance
server as well
and that is why we say customers can be
up and running in a matter of
hours if not days definitely not you
know it's not going to take you weeks
months to do it
it's it's so simple to use if if
our existing nedisa customers coming
from twin fins and stripers and makos
they know how easy it is to move from a
twin fin to a striper to a striper to a
mako for example
it's exactly the same got it got it that
sounds fantastic so basically netize is
practically delivering out of the box
easy performance
correct awesome mike let's talk about
the the hardware changes that we've made
a little bit i understand for an ateza
performance server this is actually now
our ninth
hardware refresh to netezza um can you
speak to
what is still there what hasn't changed
what has changed
and with those changes what are some of
the performance improvements that our
customers can expect
sure absolutely um so ninth generation
right depending on who's doing the
counting but absolutely
you are well i'm going to counting it's
not
right so uh and i've been around for
them uh and seen the way that they have
you know gone down et cetera but as you
mentioned
you know over the course of manitesa
life
cycles um you know we've brought to bear
various new technology releases
enhancements etc always bringing in
opportunities where we've got a cost
benefit and a performance benefit
from any modernization that we've done
right never made sense in an adhesive
architecture
to bring in you know the fastest disk
drive or the fastest cpu stack
because it's a balanced system right
it's an mpp system
that really gets to the heart of your
question right so what still remains
well what still remains that is neteza
is really all of it
it's just that next generation of
hardware just as we've always brought
at the right and appropriate time new
modernized elements
we've stayed true to the dna right the
dna is
you know the postgresql derivative right
so our great great grandfather i like to
say is postgres
right that's where matisse originated
that gives us the great interoperability
with the third-party ecosystems
it gives us a great story around open
source
and it's really easy to deal with now
what we've done in the pizza over the
years has taken that that postgres
shell and we've extended it into the
enterprise right we've given enterprise
class standard and feature sets to that
code base and continue to evolve them
it's one of the things and we'll talk
about this a little bit later that
really differentiates us from some of
the uh startups
that you're seeing come into the data
warehousing market where they like
netezza have said
you know let's leverage this database
engine this postgres
engine and let's throw it out there on
commodity hardware
well having lived through it the first
time it's not really that simple is it
it takes a lot of engineering it takes a
lot of sophistication it takes a lot of
really good
software to get to that point where
you take a system like an antesa and you
make it capable
for enterprise workloads so i'd say you
know specifically to your question
the dna is there right so the dna is
there in terms of mpp the dna is there
in terms
of things like zone mapping that speaks
to the simplicity that you talked about
earlier
the things that are net new um the
storage subsystem
so those of you that have been around
the teaser for a long time
typically when a bottleneck did occur in
the teaser it was in the form of disk i
o
right so with analytic queries you hit a
disk i o
bound it's typically the first thing
that you hit the new storage subsystem
being
ssd driven goes right to the heart of
that
immediately goes and attacks that
traditional bottleneck
but at the same time not compromising
any of the ways that you speak
to and work with and live within the
tisa system
so true to the dna but injecting a whole
host of new modernized hardware
just as we've always done nine times
that's great so with all of these
performance improvements vikram i bet
when we're running pocs we probably see
that in the field as well
so i know since launch you have done
dozens and dozens of these client pocs
from a performance standpoint how does
an ateza performance server compare
to you know our customers twin fins and
stripers or if they have the later makos
how does it compare against those
systems
that's that's a great question so i'm
going to answer it uh two different ways
so one
we do a lot of benchmarking and testing
in-house
and then the second part of it is when
our customers really install it
and they tell us you know what their
experience is
so what we have seen across the board if
a customer is coming from
let's say a twin fin or a striper we are
about five to eight times
faster and when a customer is coming
from amako
we are about two times faster when it
comes to load performance and we are
about three times faster when it comes
to sql performance
now these are i believe very
conservative numbers
it completely depends on workloads that
you're running
and that's why i say you know i like to
listen to what our customers have to say
the ones who have invested in nedisa
performance server and who are already
in production
and some of these customers are telling
us they are seeing speed bumps of
about 15 to 20 x compared to their older
systems
i mean it's just unbelievable one
customer
actually wrote me an email and he told
me
that he thought his jobs had errored out
on his previous generation edisa system
it used to take about 15 minutes for him
to run a particular set of jobs
and in this one it completed in about a
minute and a half
and he thought there is no way it could
have completed that fast
it must have errored out and he was
pleasantly surprised
that it was that fast so i mean we love
i love to see such
emails that's true appreciation and
as i said we can do whatever benchmarks
we want in-house
but the true testimony comes from
customers and we are getting
you know customer testimonials on a
daily basis how fast it is
that's incredible um so now let's talk a
little bit about the the new
architecture mike
in the past and mike you definitely
recall this since you've lift and
breathed it
when a customer has outgrown their
existing netiza environment let's say
they are going from a two rack and they
need to go
to a four rack they basically had to buy
an entire
new four rack we ship it in they put it
next to their two rack they have to load
the data synchronize the data
it's an extremely complicated cumbersome
process
now can you talk about what our new
architecture for native performance
server is like today
and how our customers can can grow and
expand on a teaser performance server
yeah absolutely and you're not wrong so
traditionally it was always a uh
an uncomfortable moment in the
conversation when we talked about
upgrade and expandability right you've
got this great thing
you're encouraging them to use more of
it they are using more of it
they outgrow it come back and say mike
my one rack or my two rack system is not
enough anymore
what can you do for me and that
conversation was always just as you said
carmen it was
you know what i can do is bring in a
four rack or a two rack system
and i can take up some data you know
some data center space and i can
synchronize between the two
and ultimately i'll take that one away
right but the the interruption if you
will that that
uh that drove into the applications or
into the workloads
uh was never a great part of the
conversation it was always the part that
it was like
yeah but this this little other piece
for expandability
um so we've addressed that in the form
of you know cloud being our
inspiration right so on demand or very
small
increments of expandability so cloud is
an inspiration
but having to deliver it to an on-prem
appliance
um so we've brought two really good
things number one
is the steps of growth is much smaller
than it's ever been
so you're not talking about doubling or
quadrupling the environment anymore
which is what we had you know with the
earlier lines so now you're talking
about just layering in
you know smaller expansion nodes that
are a much smaller step
so the customers and you know i'm with
customers all the time as you know
they're very very intrigued by that and
if they feel very good to not need to
over buy you know on a five year or a
three year cycle
they can expand over time in increments
so that small step is number one
the second step of that which is really
key is that it's in field expandable
right so the the system doesn't go away
no we don't rip out the entirety the
host etc
we're going to expand these systems in
field so there's a lot less disruption
from an operational perspective as well
we come in slide in an additional
set of expansion nodes in the existing
racks etc
and off you go with bigger capacity so
now small steps
and in-field expandability are key
what i'll call modernized elements to it
fantastic so what might just describe
the small incremental
growth that that's basically allowing
our customers to go from gigabytes to i
think multi-petabytes they can scale in
a teaser performance server now
so can you talk a little bit about what
are some of the additions
and specifically to our customers uh who
have tiny footprint with netezza
before can you talk about what are some
of the additions that we have made to
the neteza performance server since we
launched it a year ago
absolutely so one thing we did in june
of this year
is we introduced what we call a design
the base and this is a very small form
factor of nedisa
it it can install in basically two
enclosures
and as mike was saying we have
technically gone away from
calling this an appliance because when
we say an appliance
it's it's it's like a toaster you know
it can do one thing
what we have right now it's a hyper
convert system
and the advantages of such a system is
that you can do data science you can do
machine learning there are
cloud pack for data a platform
capabilities and features are available
as well
and that's why expansions you can grow
one enclosure at a time
so now we have netiza installed in that
one single enclosure
so for those customers who want a really
small footprint
and you keep in mind you can keep
growing at a later date if you want to
but they can start with something really
small and as mike mentioned you don't
have to pay for something you won't use
until year three or four
right now just start small and you can
keep growing so that's one thing that we
have done
now the other thing we did in june of
this year was we also introduced nedisa
on the cloud
uh it's available on two clouds it's
available on ibm cloud as well as
amazon cloud and we are working on
bringing it to azure it's going to come
around the november time frame this year
and soon after it will come on google
cloud as well so now customers have a
true choice of going
wherever they want and we fully
understand every customer is in a
different phase of their cloud journey
but guess what you don't have to make
that decision right now so you can
get an on-prem system whatever work you
do that including applications
you know whatever development work you
do there you can move to the cloud at
your pace
and we have netize available on these
two clouds ibm and amazon right now
and as i said azure and google very soon
fantastic so it sounds like that there's
that portability element that our
customers would also appreciate too
because if they're running on-prem today
and they want to take that cloud pack
for data software and run it somewhere
else tomorrow they can do it
do it at their own pace and then also
for the customers like you mentioned who
are preferring a much smaller footprint
and only wants to focus on the netezza
use case today they can start at the
base system
you can actually do an nz migrate
directly through an s3 bucket
and you don't have to even move the file
the nedisa on-prem system does it for
you
and from that s3 bucket you can do a you
know restore or
you know you can you can pull the file
down on your cloud system
so imagine the compatibility you can
actually even backup
your on-prem system and restore it into
the cloud system so it's truly flexible
i honestly don't believe there's another
edw that offers you that level of
flexibility
amazing so aside from flexibility with
native performance server running on red
hat open shift mic
all the analytic activities also gets
consolidated into one place which is
where the data resides
can you talk a little bit about how
native performance server
is specifically not just only helping
our analysts how is it also simplifying
the work for data scientists as well
absolutely
what we see today and what we see
emerging is
you know like never before the notion of
co-location is important again
right as we look to you know some of my
data is in the cloud
some of my data is on-prem some of my
data is
unconformed other is not et cetera
so the idea and the challenge behind
someone trying to
achieve analytics or to do data science
against all of this varying data that
lives in different places and comes from
different systems
so the notion of being able to collocate
or pre-integrate
functionality together has become
interesting again
this new generation of netiza is a child
of cloud pack for data and in addition
to the netezza feature set in
functionality
cloud pasture data has a very broad
spectrum
of analytic tools right so machine
learning tools data science tools
cataloging and cleansing tools etc all
of these
you know ecosystem partners the data
warehouses have always needed
right have always needed to be
integrated together with them
and that was the long pole in the tent
was actually bringing them together
pre-integrating it getting it to the
point where
a knowledge worker or a data scientist
or even back in the day an analyst
could go in and make heads or tails of
all this different data
from a common repository i think we've
done a really nice job as it relates to
cloud pack for data
and i couldn't be more thrilled to see
netiza which in my opinion
is our bread and butter data warehouse
to see that
sitting as heart and lung of cloud pack
for data
so it's pretty exciting time that's my
feeling
let's also talk about some of our
existing netizea customers
who are still running on their very old
twin fin striper
systems that have been out of support
for what over a year now for some of
them right and still not upgrading
i think primarily these customers they
kind of fall into two buckets
in my mind a is they are running
completely unsupported
b is they probably acquired some
uncertified unsanctioned third-party
support and they're trying to extend the
life of these boxes a little bit longer
so vikram can you talk a little bit
about the risk and exposures for
for all these customers customers have a
lot of choice
they love their older eza system so much
that they want to
hold on to it but there's a lot of risk
involved in it
the the main issue i see is if you look
at the software aspect of nedisa
ibm we have access to the code we have
the code
and we develop fixes for defects and we
you know
routinely give customers defect fixes
security patches and so on if you go to
a third party
and try to get a support from them my
only caution to such customers would be
make sure what you're signing up for
because when your system is down
and when you need a patch to go fix that
system
i don't see how these third parties will
be able to provide you that path because
they don't have access to our source
code
right and they don't have our experience
fixing these
defects i would really ask them to take
another look at nedisa performance
server
because as everything that we said it's
a modern engine right now
there should be no inhibition in going
to this modern engine
and you don't have to spend months or
years trying to
upgrade your netizea system from your
old system to new system
in a matter of days if not weeks you can
actually just upgrade to the netizer
performance server
and that's the latest and greatest i
would be very cautious in going with
third party support
because i i just don't see how they'll
be able to support
customers in business critical
applications and this is your data
warehouse it's a very mission critical
asset
and i think mike you've actually talked
to some customers recently right where
they have gone to extend the support on
third-party support and
they basically weren't able to get their
netizes stood back up again after it
crashed
we've seen it manifest itself really in
two ways
number one the software fixes all right
the
security patches etc that can get really
really scary
you know especially if you think about
you know the cyclical nature
of data warehousing cyclical nature of
our customers themselves
so you know imagine a retailer heading
into holiday season
that believe it or not we are heading in
the holiday season for 2020
um so you know the typical thing you do
is you prep
are my systems ready are my people ready
and am i updated on software
my security patches in place is my
system healthy
right and we've had examples where
customers are asking those questions now
and trying to prepare for holiday or
wherever their cyclical pump is and
work um only to find that no you're
locked into that release
when you came off of ibm support
we've got the patch from then we can
give you that but it doesn't fix
this or hey these four disk drives that
you want to
to swap out because they're starting to
degrade a little bit
we don't have this they're not available
because this is 15 year old technology
right
so as these systems start to age and
they get older
you actually will see as you would
expect you see hardware failures start
to increase
and they increase you know cliff light
right you start to see them increase
much more frequently than maybe you had
in the first five years
a scary notion to uh to entrust an edw
workload
to you know any firm that can't offer
you a software upgrade or guarantee the
availability of parts
precarious position so aside from these
two buckets of customers who haven't
upgraded from their twin fins and
stripers
there's also an increasing number of
clients that we are working with
nowadays who have
perhaps moved off of ibm and chosen a
different modernization path
but now they are kind of coming back to
us because they are dealing with a very
painful very long and complex migration
elsewhere
and also they're realizing that it is
actually extremely expensive and some of
them have been
unpleasantly surprised by how high their
total cost of ownership actually is
mike i know you've actually been
engaging with a lot of these customers
can you dive a little bit more into some
of the challenges that these customers
have shared with you
sure absolutely and that you know i
always go back to like a historical
story you know
with neteza and we used to joke that we
spent the first three to five years at
netiza educating the market to what an
appliance was
and we spent the second ten years of the
teaser pre-acquisition
explaining what an appliance wasn't and
what we meant
by that was this whole fleet of
competition
um came and started to to bite at the
appliance
methodology and the client's vernacular
et cetera
so they started to portray themselves as
something that they want
yet i find myself in very much the same
situation today where there's a whole
host of
of competitors that have now come out
and they're starting to position
against ews and starting to position you
know farther and farther
into the market and they're doing so
with you know immature database engines
obviously
um day you begin as the least mature
that you are and over time you become
more and more mature
so we see that kind of stuff certainly
coming up but i would say the number one
thing that we're seeing is
is really the business models themselves
and the notions
that have been portrayed to the
customers around the opportunity to save
money or to turn off
infrastructure during down times or
you know the way that one scales right
so we see a lot of uh of dissatisfaction
with uh cost predictability so you know
i
i went down this path expecting i was
going to need
you know these three clusters um and
what it ended up that during my peak
time i need 10.
you know by the way i can't turn any of
this down because edw's run 24 by 7.
why didn't i realize that so that's
really where it's coming back to them
it's uh it's not what i thought it was
it's more expensive
i'm not sure how i'm going to scale it
for the entirety of my workload
that's what it is i i would imagine just
about every single customer is facing
increasing pressure with you know
budget cut and trying to do more with
less so
can you talk about specifically and i'll
start with you vikram
how netizea performance server is
practically designed
to really help our customers save money
and cost optimize
if you look at nedisa performance server
today we actually
support jdbc odbc drivers going all the
way to version 5.
that is almost 10 years back so if you
have homegrown applications
the people who might have written those
applications might not even be with your
company anymore
now do you want to re-architect
everything they're working perfectly
fine
you don't have to do any of that all
those drivers
odbc jdbc drivers all of that is
supported assets
so you all you need to do is point those
applications to the new nida performance
server
so imagine the time that you will save
when it comes to
you know moving from the older to new
system edw migrations can take
months if not years i've been with data
warehousing for almost 15 years now
and i've seen customers do that it's
like you know it's a heart transplant
you cannot just change a database
bring in a new database and say i'm done
right so
especially in the middle of a pandemic
right now customers are
looking to save the only risk free
option as i previously said is going to
be for them to go to netizea performance
server
and it's going to save them a lot not
only in the short term but
in the longer term as well yeah on a
similar threat piggybacking off of what
you just said
i think another important thing for us
to also touch on is on
cross-generational support
because a lot of our customers who are
migrating off of netezza onto an
entirely different platform
basically has to do a floor sweep and
rip and replace everything so can you
also speak a little bit about that and
how
they can save money with that yeah
absolutely we have a lot of twin fin
striper and mako customers and by the
way makos
you know the support is there for the
next several years we have customers
mako customers who are actually moving
their production makeover workload to
nedisa performance server
and instead using the makos for test and
development the other thing is if
you invest and buy nedisa performance
server today
we will eventually do a hardware refresh
it might be next year or the year after
we will support interoperab operability
again
which means the system that you have
today you can keep it for dev test or
production
and you can bring in a new system to be
your new production
so there's so much flexibility that we
offer
that i don't see how anyone else can
offer that i think a lot of our
customers are also looking
these days to consolidate what they have
in their data center so can you also
talk a little bit about from an
infrastructure standpoint
how native performance server this new
generation is also helping them save
money with this consolidation effort
if you compare nedisa performance server
to our previous generation systems
the footprint that we occupy is
massively less some customers have even
told us it's one-fifth of the footprint
we went away from the appliance model
and if a customer can now give us
more power and cooling per rack we can
actually fit
more within a rack so we have come to a
customized solution
where you can put more servers per rack
but even without that
even comparing rack to rack our massive
reduction in footprint will just reduce
the amount of power and cooling
a customer will have to bring in and it
also reduces tile space
so just there the cost of ownership the
true cost of ownership
is massively reduced there's a huge
difference between
you know what we've coined as a
frictionless upgrade and what we've even
experienced ourselves you know over the
years with with a true migration
right a true migration where you're
touching every bit
of adjacent code be it etl be it bi
be it administrative code you know all
of these things that have grown up like
an
onion around your edw when you migrate
your engine
and god forbid you migrate your engine
at the same time that you're migrating
to a new deployment style
you're just inserting lots and lots of
variability into the equation
right and no one wants to talk about
risk and variability
only to have parity on the other side
right so the only check mark
is i quote unquote modernized right um
but the net net is i spent a lot of time
and i spent a lot of money
only to get parity on the other side
right so
it's amazing the difference between an
upgrade and a migration
i would imagine with no tuning no
indexing very minimal administration and
ongoing maintenance
there is a lot of cost savings tied to
that as well correct absolutely
absolutely
as mike mentioned you're going to save
cost on migration because there's no
migration
the simplicity of neteza which is what
neteza is famous for in the last
15 16 years we have carried that over
and as i said i know of a lot of
customers who don't even have
a separate administrator to go
administer their netizen box
i've had customers call us say i think
one of our disk drives needs replacement
but we have no idea
which data center on itizer box is
sitting right so it's a true
install it and forget about it type of
system and that's what we have carried
over
going to neriza performance server is
the true
zero risk option it's not only from a
cost saving
option it is zero administration ease of
use
simplicity all of those things it's it's
one of the best edw's out there
mike any final thoughts before we uh
wrap up this webinar today
yeah i mean i think i would would close
with just really a market
observation spending a lot of time with
the customers
you know what's really emerged in my
mind right now with the edw
market is that it's a tangible thing
right
the notion of modernization everybody's
got a different definition of what
modernization
is or isn't etcetera right and
everyone's going to take credit for some
level of modernization
but the idea of an edw is very tangible
right there's a start and there's a
finish and there's an evolution
to what it is and what it's doing so
therefore
you know i'm seeing a tremendous amount
of
quote-unquote modernization is nailing
use cases
like data warehousing that are very
definable we understand costs we
understand activity we understand
processes etc so it's a really exciting
time for data warehousing right
it's it's definable it's tangible and
therefore
it's at the front end of modernization
whatever that might mean to you
so it's a great conversation um the
netezza base couldn't be more charged up
uh some of the best conversations most
happy conversations i've had in the last
10 years
i've been in the last year when we've
reintroduced the uh the netezza engine
and you see these size relief and
gratitude etc that we found a way to
bring it back
um so it's just a really energetic time
for data warehousing in general and uh
and then the teaser base is
charged up mike vikram thank you so much
for your time today and for those of you
who have tuned in to watch thank you so
much and if you're interested
here's our contact information and some
webpages for you to find out more
information
from all of us at silicon valley lab
thank you again
thank you thank you
[Music]
you